hi my name is Samuel Leeds and in this
video I wanted to explain really how I
bought my first buy to that property and
I did that just before my 18th birthday
so I was I was actually 17 when I bought
my first house with no money not from a
wealthy background reasonably
working-class and no one gave me a penny
no one gave me a penny so I'll share how
I did that and hopefully it will inspire
some of you guys the thing is I'm not
the only one you know there's many
people that have been trained by me and
not me there's many people in this
country that have been buying properties
with no money
starting at a ridiculously young age but
how it works so first let me just say
this I didn't have a penny off anybody
so no one gave me a penny I'm not from a
wealthy background so in that way I
didn't rely on anybody you know
sometimes people say just because I did
really well really young sometimes
people say oh you know you you just
helped out by your parents or people
must have given you money or you know
you're privileged or whatever that's
completely not that's not the case but
at the same time I relied completely I
depended on three people heavily for the
deal to happen so Arnold Schwarzenegger
says that no one's self-made so while no
one gave me any money and while I did it
from scratch I did rely on people so the
three people that I really relied on one
person was a family member who didn't
give me any money but a family member
who let me put the property in their
name because I was too young to buy
property and I remember actually when I
was 17 and I was starting hanging
property I just get on all these
training programs I had a mentor a
member thinking I can't wait until I'm
18 and I can buy a house you know no
money down and then I got told by my
mortgage broker or ex broker no no you
have to be 21 to get a buy select
mortgage and you have to have a
residential mortgage first and you need
this and this and this and I'm like oh
my goodness all this training that I've
done and I can't even buy a house in
some 21 and then my mentor said to me
yes but you could get a mortgage Hutt's
and you could put the property in
someone else's name like a family
member's name and I'm like thinking oh
my goodness well if I can do it that way
I don't even have to wait until I'm 18 I
can literally do it straightaway so
first person I'm gonna give a shout out
to is the person
the founding member and there was more
than one who said to me yes I'm you I'm
happy too I'm happy for you too bought a
house in my name as long as it doesn't
cost me anything so no I gave me any
money but as long he doesn't cost me
anything I can do that
and I tell you something I bet you any
money if you're knowledgeable
trustworthy and have good family I bet
there's someone in your family that
would put a house in their name on your
behalf because worst case we're having
you screwed them over how can you screw
them like you screw them and they'll
just say okay well I'll keep the house
man you know so there's no risk that's
the first thing that happened second
person I relied heavily on was my mental
I know several mentors I still do have
mentors who basically told me exactly
what to do and I want to tell you how I
did it how I find out stating how it
structured there in a second but second
thing is the mentor who taught me
exactly how to do it now sometimes when
a mental tells you how to do something
or what to do
you don't necessarily even know how it
works you just know that it does so for
instance in in my office's right now if
I go in and I press a light switch I
know that the whole office building
could light up with one light switch I
know that I don't know how it works but
I know that if I press the button I know
it happens for my mentor and several
mentors that told me what to do and I
just followed the instruction shout out
to those guys third person I depended on
was my mortgage broker my lender so let
me tell you how I did the deal really
simple
some of you might think it sounds too
good to be true or well I did it so it
isn't too good to be true because I did
it and not only did I do it but many of
my students and many many many people
have so there was a property on the
market it was no joke it was it was
valued at 100,000 pound I agreed to buy
the property at negotiated price of
80,000 pounds so 20,000 pounds below the
asking price below the market value I
bought it about 80,000 pounds and I
bought it in cash because my mortgage
company gave me a bridging loan all done
in my family Amber's name so I bought it
for cash for 80 grand by then the same
day I bought it
age 17 refinance debt back up to its
true value of 100 poured the 80 grand
out paid the lender back on I now have a
house for free using none of my own
money just relying on those three people
now of course I have a mortgage too
right now some people would say Sam you
you didn't buy a house at 17 you didn't
own the house the banks owned it yes the
banks owned it true you know so it's
it's I did it it's technically my house
in a phone numbers name being funded by
the bank but who benefits from the rent
who benefits from the capital
depreciation me so the mortgage payments
were I think 166 panamath I rent it out
as a HMO ruined by room 1400 Panama so
that first property before my 18th
birthday was given me 1,400 pounds a
month range not a bad deal another bad
deal
I saw a finance DEP that's how I rented
it out so I think the moral of the story
is don't ever say that's too good to be
true because there's a lot of good
things going on right now and very
wealthy people in very successful people
you won't hear them saying it's too good
to be true and then secondly don't be
afraid to depend on people don't be
afraid to ask for help I ask people for
help I press the light switch the lights
come on I don't understand it all I
don't try and understand the X what X Y
Z before I step out and do the ABC so
take action educate yourself don't be
afraid to ask for help that's how I find
out to my first deal if you've got any
questions about that or you don't
understand it feel free to comment below
the markets have changed now so now that
was that was back in like that was ten
years ago can you believe it I'm 27 now
almost 28 I've been investing now for
over ten years ten years or more so the
markets changed so now the way I
structured deals is very different but
that was the first one you can still do
very similar things you can still buy
add value and refinance there's a whole
world out there there's a whole world
out there which is just crazy scary
crazy good and the amount the things
that you can do just do so but if you
say it's too much to be true
why isn't you lose you too because
you've not done it before so what you're
just not going to ever do new things I'm
uncomfortable just get at your comfort
zone grow do you need things so that's
the story look for in your comments
below
god bless see you next time
[Music]